here are some tips on how to survive in
space according to the movies space
problem number one technology breakdowns
sometimes in life things go exactly as
planned
other times Kevin Bacon ruins everything
if your vessel malfunctions you'll have
little to protect yourself against space
is negative 454 degree temperature if
you need to travel to a new space
station all together be sure to stay
close to your space buddy or else you
could end up like George Clooney that's
the wrong clip try again mm-hmm if
you're not careful you could end up like
George Clooney terrific thank you clip
back now if an enemy attack has taken
out your autopilot it might be time to
take one for the fleet at the end of the
day sometimes technology just chooses to
malfunction open the pod bay doors help
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that how is such a dick space problem
number two getting stranded on another
planet so whether you're stuck on a
lifeless empty planet like Mars or a
junkyard eight field planet like Earth
you'll need to put on your game face if
you want to make it back a lot that
means getting yourself a hab a spacesuit
and sustenance for Luke Skywalker that
means snacking on a granola bar and for
Matt Damon that means growing lots of
weed of course you'll need to figure out
a way home before your supplies run out
options include but are not limited to
using what little fuel you have left to
blast back into Earth's atmosphere
getting help from your green friend
calling on a Scottish dude to beam you
back
or doing whatever Matt Damon is doing
there I don't know the movie isn't out
yet yes I know there's a book and no I
don't read finally there's always the
threat of a space alien attack but keep
in mind not all aliens are bad so before
we dive into alien survival techniques
let's review who's friendly and who's
not friendly not from me friendly not
from me friendly not friendly not from
not from me friendly not from friendly
friendly friendly friendly not friendly
and still on the fence with that one
but as Stephen Hawking has said
extraterrestrial life could potentially
destroy humanity so in the event that
you do run into the not friendly aliens
you have several options you can launch
a missile blow them away with the most
powerful alien blasters known to man
recall your hand-to-hand combat skills
well
earth or feed them Reese's Pieces in
conclusion space is a dangerous place so
remember to keep your vessel up and
running stick to your survival skills
when stranded and fight off those pesky
aliens or else you could end up like
George Clooney clip guy you know it's
okay I actually kind of like this one
wow he is good-looking
thanks for watching remember to Like
comment and subscribe to our Fandango
movie clips channel and share this with
all your friends at NASA they're
probably not busy